oh hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report well um as christine lagarde
might call it funny money
let's get into it stacy right where is
my money
because more money is being handed out
and in the second half we talk
to dominic frisbee about his new edition
of the
american version of daylight robbery
about the history of taxation it's very
fascinating
but it's relevant to today because as we
see
the money printer it's the same story
that's been going on since ancient
mesopotamia of
of men with guns as paul krugman calls
them like to come around and collect
some of your money or try to
redistribute it around as favors to some
groups of people over other groups of
people
well biden should send every american as
much money as jeff bezos has
we should demand it where's my money joe
that's what i had tweeted because
you know they're getting ready for
another 1.9 trillion dollars to send out
and they're trying to allocate
who gets it this time and of course the
last go-around we saw
basically the oligarchs plunder most of
it ordinary people did receive
quite a bit but now they're handing out
some more money you know the problem
is the money itself
that's the problem so therefore the
solution
to any of the perceived problems can
never be to
hand out more of the foundational
problem
and that is the money itself this fiat
money
since 1971 no fiat money in the world
has ever been
really now connected to anything that
you would equate with a store of value
it's just basically an accounting fraud
essentially in the united states they
print trillions and trillions of dollars
they claw back some of that in taxes
which is completely unnecessary
they drop it by the trillions on the
pallet
load full in places like iraq without
any accountability whatsoever
and then there's always this question
like why is everything so messed up
why is the country falling apart why is
there social unrest
without understanding and paul krugman
is
to be the the most blind to this of
anyone in the united states
it's the money what's that saying
something along the lines of like if you
show me who pays them then i'll show you
the incentive
and the incentive structure truly
charlie munger so you know you tune into
the cable news you tune
in to any political debate and what you
see is the fact that as
dominic frisbie points out in the
interview that you're about to see
is all of these measures going back to
ancient mesopotamia we start as a
temporary thing
always the population only allows it
if there's a war or a crisis so thus it
becomes
especially in a fiat age a permanent
crisis we have permanent financial
collapse we have permanent wars i don't
know how many
my taxes right now go to support around
the world but there are plenty of them
right now happening so you have
permanent uh you know
bad times permanent pessimism that's
that's why in bitcoin what we call it
and that was the the title
of our new year's eve show is relentless
optimism
because all the incentives are
not to have war not to waste it on
killing people around the world that you
don't even know for no reason at
all so i think we could change that it's
funny because back in the medieval times
the
problem were despots and kings
and they had the authority to just take
not money but
pay in kind as it was called we take
part of your crop we take
your part of your family we'll take your
daughter you know we'll take whatever we
want to take and then there is this
whole process starting with magna carta
leading to the enlightenment leading to
the rights of man leading to the
constitution and the bill of rights
where there was power
was supposed to be uh balanced in the
social contract as john locke called it
and but what we've got now in the united
states and around the world is a return
to despotism
did taxation uh based on uh the spurious
it's just spurious taxation
without any accountability that's a
that's that we're back to the middle
ages
bitcoin is holding it accountable and
that's um
that's what you see on cnbac actually
there are literally uh
presenters going on there and pleading
with the us government to do to
something to stop it because the us
dollar will die they're saying if
if if this continues so remember last
year
in what was it april or may when we
handed out twelve hundred dollars to
everybody
under a certain income well that twelve
hundred dollar stimulus is now worth
seven thousand eight hundred and nine
dollars that's up five hundred and fifty
one percent since then of course i mean
a lot of stuff is
up a lot right that's that's the
taxation without
legislation as dominic frisbee calls it
that's the inflation
that is happening inflation is taxation
well this is the ultimate
win win win for people who have a
ability to see clearly the
uh problem the reason why bitcoin is
skyrocketing is because there's
hyperinflation in america
and the u.s dollar is in a
hyperinflationary collapse against
bitcoin and the solution as we've been
describing
by these policy makers will always be
to print more money so that means that
bitcoin is on a one-way trip higher
because they have no other policy
solution than to print
money so therefore that stimulus money
is up five or six hundred percent it's
going to be up six thousand percent
uh and it's gonna and continue to go
higher because the policy makers
are compl this arbitrary despotism we
see
in washington and other power centers
around the world is fueled by hubris
and rank imbecility and they're just
going to keep printing
and well you know my bitcoins up 9
million percent
since i first bought it and it's
probably going to go up another 40x
well the hyperinflation of course is
a um you know it's a political event
it's when people lose
faith in the institutions that are
governing the currency governing the
money
and we certainly see that we've seen
that with um the disintegration
you know in riots across the world but
also in america because back in 2008
they weren't
i mean we we had occupy wall street that
happened and that was quickly dispersed
but it does seem like there's
like breakaway sort of groups starting
to be um dissatisfied and i think that
could be a sign
of that and bitcoin you know that
bitcoin price is showing you seven
thousand eight hundred and nine dollars
for that 1200 stimulus check it's up 551
since it was first issued that's like
how the wealthy get to live right
they they front run everybody these uh
more checks are coming
you know biden's meeting with jamie
dimon and all these bankers to decide
yeah how much
he's telling them what he's going to
give you so that jamie dimon can make
sure he stays a billionaire right and
that you
you get you know the ordinary chump
getting some money that doesn't inflate
away he because he doesn't want to pay
taxes right because remember dominic
frisbie says inflation is a tax
so he doesn't want to pay those taxes
he's not going to pay them so what's he
going to do he's going to buy bitcoin
he's going to buy
assets he's going to buy commodities
like stan druckenmiller he's going to go
very very short at the dollar like stan
druckenmiller he's going to
you know buy mediglianis as maxwell he
says or picassos
yeah jamie dimon is the dr kevorkian of
economics if he shows up in your office
you know you've got trouble big trouble
and uh there's
the administration talking to this
euthanasia doctor named
jamie dimon about how best to euthanize
america and jamie says the best way to
euthanize america is to print money
well certainly the us dollars euthanized
the u.s dollar and it could be better
for everybody after it's gone so
hopefully you know from the majority of
people and i don't think it's going to
be
so good for the the jamie diamonds of
the world but for the bottom 99
i think it's going to be better if it's
not the reserve currency because
remember you have to
run a massive trade deficit to have the
us dollar
as the world's reserve currency um sure
they get to
you know be men with guns and thug
thuggery and
you know beat people up that they don't
like like in iran or venezuela or
whatever and they get to shut them off
from the grid
but at a huge cost to your own domestic
population
now we look at another bitcoin story and
of course i mean this is kind of funny
because everybody hates elon musk
of course on wall street everybody hates
him in the mainstream media
that he keeps succeeding he keeps
delivering
results for his shareholders whether
it's in tesla or spacex he keeps
like like everybody you know kind of in
the mainstream media the orthodoxy
they wanted his spacex to fail but it
was brilliant it went to the
space station and delivered all that
stuff well you know
as we covered you know he bought 1.5
billion dollars worth of
bitcoin for tesla tesla are already up
over 500 million dollars
on their bitcoin investment nearly
outperforming their entire
2020 earnings of 721 million
they've made more on their tesla
investment in less than six months
than they've ever made in the entirety
on their
business of selling cars yes on their
bitcoin rather than a tesla on their
bitcoin
and that actually brings up they could
have bought instead
more their own shares that's the
standard thing to do
but micah sailor of microstrategy blew
that um
operation out of the water well because
as i've explained this is
based on the 1993 soros attack on the
bank of england which was a speculative
attack
he could borrow money cheaply from these
banks and attack a big bank like the
bank of england
forced them out of the european exchange
rate mechanism and made a quick billion
dollars and stan
druckenmiller orchestrated that
speculative attack this is a
speculative attack that elon musk is
making on the fed
right so he's already gone to war with
the sec the sec
he's already gone to war with the sec
and he's shown them to be venal
and captured now he's gone to war with
the fed
and say i'm not gonna buy back my own
stock i'm gonna take your cheap money
i'm gonna buy
bitcoin like michael saylor's doing and
now you know 500 other
ceos in the s p 500 are like you know
what that's a darn good idea
the sec is that what you call the sec is
that the word you use on wall street
the sec yeah it's like an abbreviation
the sec yeah the sec
i've never heard that all right well you
know there are all these emergencies
financial crashes caused by all the
fraud and wall street and all this
chaos that ensues and everybody i
remember back in 2008
that the people called their congressmen
to pass that tarp
because their stock prices went down the
stock portfolios went down
so of course it's permanent since then
right this permanent qe since 2008.
so you know these nonstop crises cause
all this inflation and this non-stop
taxation and the the hamster whale of
like ever having to create evermore to
be stolen ever more
so i i want to look at this quick
headline here this is just
just a reflection of the absurdity of
the society and culture
and economy around us in 2040 we will
collectively decide to flood the
atmosphere
with aerosols and that's because of all
the co2 in the atmosphere
again because we have fiat money we have
this uh never-ending need to keep on
printing more in order to tax more
through inflation in order to continue
our wars
against um the economy essentially
like where we this is this is the way we
operate is
all right well mike judge made a great
movie called idiocracy
yeah and they were watering their front
lawn with a sports drink
yeah wondering why the grass died and
then somebody who was reanimated from
the past
was brought back to life who had some
brain cells left from the past and he
became president overnight
because he knew that you shouldn't water
the grass with
uh gatorade uh so this is literally
going into idiocracy the land now yeah
the the
institutional level is so broken down in
basilic
that they can't like walk and chew gum
at the same time much less run an
economy i would say that's also a good
analogy for all the money printing this
is exactly as insane as what the central
banks are doing
oh insanity is trading up
in america and around the world when we
come back we're going to be talking to
dominic frisbee about
his book daylight robbery don't go away
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to go to
dominic frisbie he's the author of
daylight robbery which will soon be
available all over the united states of
america dominic welcome back to the
kaiser report
thanks very much max yup daylight rubber
it comes out in the u.s this week
i'm delighted now remind the audience of
how daylight robbery is a term
coined off of uk taxes and what are the
most unique traits
of u.s taxes i mean it really is a
fascinating story dominic tell us a
little bit more about it
well the expression daylight robbery its
thought dates back to the window tax
which we had in the uk
and it was introduced in 1694 i think
uh shortly after the glorious revolution
uh in order to pay for lots of wars
abroad
all taxes are always introduced to pay
for wars and um
it it like a lot of taxes it just stayed
for much longer than it should and
people started building houses
with fewer and fewer windows in order to
avoid paying the tax people blocked up
their windows
altogether and entire tenement blocks
were built with no windows at all
and in those days there was no electric
light there was no gas lights there were
no oil lamps
we lit with candles and um rush lights
so to lose your daylight was no small
sacrifice
and it had the consequence of making um
the unintended consequence of making
people
far more ill than they need have been
during the industrial revolution the
damped cramped windowless dwellings
contributed to the outbreaks of
cholera and typhus and all the rest of
it and for years there were campaigns
songs were sung the pamphlets were
handed out
scientific studies were shown to prove
that the tax made people made
people ill but people still continued
with it and when the
matter was eventually debated in
parliament it said that mps cried out
daylight robbery and that's where the
expression comes from the other
expression we get
from taxation is nosy parker mr parker
was the tax collector apparently
um there's all sorts of weird things in
our lives that date back to some kind of
historical
tax story that we didn't previously that
maybe people don't realize right the
beatles didn't they do a song about the
tax man uh you know it's
so much part of popular culture and of
course america decided they had enough
of your taxes and we
staged the revolutionary war to get rid
of those taxes but now we're out taxing
and almost out taxing
you guys after let me ask you this
question dominic frisbee
after trillions of dollars were printed
and sent to individuals and companies
across america last year
many are now thinking why do we need
taxes in an all fiat world when all this
money is printed i mean this is a
question that comes up now
the government printed in one week as
uh money that equaled all of last year's
tax take
so why even bother take why why why
bother to if you can just print the
money dominic
i don't know this is the argument that
gets used why do you need taxation if
you have a magic money tree
and the answer that's given is that you
need tax in order to stop inflation
never mind that they're inflating by
printing money the statistic that i read
is that 25
of us dollars in existence were printed
last
year and of course inflation
is just taxation by another means it's
another way of extracting wealth
milton friedman called it called it
taxation without
legislation now it's great that you
mention
uh the american revolution and how
american was built on low taxes but this
is the sort of cycle
that empires and nations and governments
go through they
their heyday is when taxes are very low
10 15 20
of gdp but gradually it creeps up over
time and as it does the state grows
corruption grows innovation strength
shrinks inventiveness shrinks
and uh it's just this sort of steady
creep
but you do need some kind of war
in order to introduce or a crisis to
introduce there's this
long relationship between tax and war
tax makes war possible
uh taxes how you pay for war you tax and
then you you plunder and then you tax
afterwards but also war
makes tax possible many there's history
is littered with examples of leaders
trying to
introduce new taxes during peace time
and it never works there it
often results in there being overthrown
but with a war
you get the opportunity to impose the
new tax and then after the crisis has
passed
taxation never goes back to the level at
which it was before the crisis started
and you even see that if quantitative
easing is attacked and i think it is
um you know that would never have been
passed
were it not for 2008 in the banking
crisis
but now it's normal and this new one
covered all sorts of money printing has
gone on there
and it's yeah the magic money tree has
been normalized max
right now nobel economist paul krugman
said that the us dollar is
better than bitcoin because the u.s
dollar is quote backed by men with guns
i.e the tax collector the armed tax
collector
now the earliest human writings are tax
records from mesopotamia which sound
remarkably like a krugman new york times
piece
tell us about what you see in
mesopotamia we talk about taxation and
i'm i'm sort of quite have a lot of
sympathy to the anarcho-capitalist
mindset as a as a bitcoiner
but in reality there has never been a
civilization
without taxation of some kind and
even in ancient messenger but even in
the hunter-gatherer societies
that predated ancient mesopotamia
there still existed this sort of sense
of duty to the greater collective and
it's interesting that word duty often
taxes the words we use for
taxes have this sort of moral
undercurrent to them
and in ancient mesopotamia the very
first written records we have
um were tax records and
their very first money we used apart
from gold and silver were little bits of
mud molded into shapes
um a cone representing a sheep a disc
representing some barley
and they were baked inside clay balls
and then when the deck was settled the
clay ball was smashed open
but then the people found that it was
actually quicker just to inscribe the
clay with pictures
instead and thus did the very first
system of hieroglyphs
and and writing emerge but these
i mean it was a bit like an early
blockchain in a way these records of
of of transactions of debts owed but the
most common debt owed was of course
taxation what you owed to your leader
tax wasn't always paid in money
of course because money wasn't
widespread in those days it was
paid in kind a share of your produce or
a share of your labor
and that word duty of course is used in
duty-free shops at the airport
meaning tax-free shops again a use of
that word
now you make the connection there you
talk about money itself
and um one of the problems is that
i mean it's remarkable that the excuse
made for collecting tax is that it needs
to stop
inflation or control inflation when as
you point out it's the very mechanism
that
is really in in the money printing is
creating the inflation
and um this idea that
somebody in the center of government can
figure out and calculate
well if we lend out a certain amount of
money through money printing and then we
claw it back through taxes and the
result is going to end up being some
kind of gdp growth
it's like uh push me pull you bicycle
isn't it it's like the
doctor doolittle with his two-headed
drama uh
dromedary they're going in two opposite
directions it makes no fundamental sense
dominic well not to me i mean i'm a i'm
a great
believer in letting you know the
aggregation of a million individual
decisions results in a better outcome
than one guy in one bureaucrat somewhere
um you know setting the law and setting
the rates and telling what everyone else
what to do and you know this kind of
meddling in the money system it's
people have done it through history and
it might not end badly immediately but
eventually it always ends badly
and um you know bitcoin is infinitely
superior the in the uh
the inflation rate of bitcoin is
transparent it's set in code it can't be
meddled with
it's there for everybody to see everyone
knows exactly how many
bitcoins are going to be printed it's
not vulnerable to the whims of some
state actor
so for paul krugman to call it inferior
to the us dollar
um you know he needs to go and have an
argument with elon musk i think
they just don't have the same opinion
about what money and what money
is and uh of course now the book is
called daylight robbery
so you've got a u.s version coming out
of this book and it really is a
fascinating
history of money taxations and kind of a
precursor to bitcoin in other words
bitcoin solves a problem the problem is
fiat money
and bureaucrats imposing taxes so that's
the problem bitcoin solves and it goes
back
many hundreds of years and of course i
could have quoted shakespeare but i
chose to quote something from dr
doolittle because i feel that was the
height
of literature achievement in your
country's history
in my opinion now there is a connection
to violence right
and right now we see
a surfeit of violence really
social violence so much so dominic in
america
they're going to be passing anti-terror
laws
against their own citizens and that's a
direct result of money printing and fiat
money printing and
you know what everything that's wrong in
the world it
comes back to fiat money not everything
that's wrong in the world but so many of
the world's problems
come back to this flawed money is the
blood of an economy
and it's essential that blood is healthy
and fiat money is not healthy
it just enables people to do things that
just shouldn't be
that shouldn't be done and you know
every single
week we come back to tax tax and money
inherently related anyone who's
interested in bitcoin
will be interested in this story anyone
who's interested in gold
the tax is how you design a society
every war in history is made possible by
some
sort of tax but also war makes tax
possible
there's this relationship and i talk a
lot about history tax throughout history
but i also talk about the future because
ta you design a society the way you tax
it whether that society
will be prosperous or poor the people
will be free or subordinated it all
comes back to the tax system tax is
power
whether it's lead government king or
emperor whoever the leader is
if they lose their tax revenue they lose
their power
and you know we need if we want to
design a better society i think most of
us do
the place to do it is the tax system
taxes this is patient zero if you get
the tax right
everything else can follow and by the
way i regard
inflation money printing as a form of
tax
taxation without legislation yeah so
many would agree with that
and it just comes back with what do you
consider to be money in this case
and in the u.s forming documents of
course they
were talking about gold and silver is
the only real money they they try to
avoid fiat money they hated the bank of
england ben franklin said it was the
chief cause for the revolution was to
get away from the bank of england
and 1694 that was just about the time
the bank of england was created if i'm
not mistaken
so it was the in order to in
we used to have a thing called the
hearth tax which was a tax on every
fireplace every stove and twice a year
tax collectors would come into your
house
and count the number of stoves you had
and it was a bit like the bbc license
fee
bloke and the um this was considered a
violation of the englishman's privacy
and so when william of orange became
king of england in order to ingratiate
himself with the newly conquered people
he got rid of the tax and then all of a
sudden he found himself without any
money
and various wars abroad which he needed
to wage and that's why he gave us
firstly
the bank of england and then the window
tax yeah fascinating the way these
things echo through history
and the our history your history is so
much enmeshed
over hundreds of years and um the tax
man has played a vital role
and uh you know what i mean it was the
american civil war that gave
america income taxes the very first time
was levied during the civil war then
during world war one
and then 1942 the revenue act that's
what brought tax to every man in america
and it was also the civil war that gave
america the irs
that was a one of another one of abraham
lincoln's great contributions
wow dominic this is fascinating i wish
we had more time but we got to say
goodbye hopefully we can pick it up when
you're
more in the u.s with your book daylight
robbery by
dominic frisbee thanks for being on the
kaiser report not at all max thanks for
having me
all right that's going to do it for this
edition of kaiser report with me max
keiser and stacey herbert want to thank
our guest dominic frisbie
until next time bye y'all
[Music]